hello everyone and the yes the rumors
you've heard have been true as of today
I am the biggest YouTube chess channel
in the world and now while that may
change tomorrow it's you know it's a
well it's definitely cool to get the
number one spot at least once but you
know we still have a lot more work to do
our subscribers video is due I hope in
some two to three weeks a week so I will
be expecting all of you to actively
engage in promoting chess like we did a
year ago I will put a link to the
subscribers video in the description
below it will be the first thing you
will see if you want to check it out and
you know maybe prepare yourselves for
what's coming and thank you all for that
- really you've been amazing
excellent subscribers and I'm very happy
to have you watching my videos the other
thing I wanted to share with you is
completely non chess related but I only
learned about it a few days ago and now
that there is this man called Steve
Wilhite I hope I'm pronouncing his name
right because it would be really funny
if I didn't he invented the gif in 1987
and it's I've read that the entire world
is mispronouncing the word that it's
actually supposed to be pronounced 2gf
and it's really funny since even the
Oxford English Dictionary says that you
can pronounce it either gif or Jif but
Steve says that you can't and he's the
one who invented it and he gets to
choose how you pronounce it but still
the the entire world ignores him and
everyone just calls it a gift but yeah I
only learned about that recently so I
thought you might enjoy that as well but
getting back to our game it's Fabiano
Carano vs. Hikaru Nakamura this is now
the Blitz
I saw the rapid time formats are over
now we head into the blitz and it's very
interesting I did use this quote above
the board that it would be weird to have
a world champion
that's bad blitz and rapid I don't know
if those are the exact words but it's
definitely in that context Nakamura
mentioned it in some interview but I'm
unable to find it if any of you have it
to do share I will either pin your
comment or you know the share is somehow
with with everyone else but it's really
an incredible game I also do hope you
enjoyed the title as it really
describe this game excellently so
without further ado let's check out our
very nice game Nakamura has the white
pieces and he opens with sorry Khurana
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 with Knight to f6 sorry about that
Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to c3 and
Bishop to g7 we have the Kings Indian
defense
efore b6 this is the stand the main line
and now h3 the macoco no variation we
have castles Bishop to e3 and now II
five Caruana grabs more space in the
center we have B 5 a 5 now stifling
White's advancement on the Queen side we
have g4 after a nice move as in a lot of
lines of the King's Indian white a black
will simply move this Knight and
prepared to push f5 at some point and
now with E 4 and g4 here it will be
somewhat difficult for black to to
execute f5 nice to a6 going after the be
for square but also covering the c5
square Knight G 2 e 2 preparing to bring
that night over to g3 we have nice to d7
and now comes Queen to d2 here a corona
created the the standard Queen Bishop
battery and is ready to exchange the
dark square bishop by playing Bishop to
h6 Knight d2 c5 a very nice move that
for now it will not be possible to go
bushel to h6 because this it would be
very unfortunate for white if this night
lands on d3 since this Knight is a
blocking the Bishop from f1 so first
night to g3 and here we have c6 by
Nakamura Bishop to e2 and now comes C
captors on d5 see captors on d5 and this
has open played before this is a pretty
much nothing new and I'm fairly certain
that both Nakamura and corona know this
but here Bishop to d7 is a move that was
known here a forest played by nakamura
and this is now a new move that was
never played before so now we have a new
game on our hands
karana continues with his attack on the
Kings side we have h4 Bishop to d7 now
and now comes h5 and okay rook to c8
nakamura simply continues developing
and now comes King to f1 Khurana now
says that he will not be castling
neither Queen side or King side that his
King will be will be fairly safe on f1
a3 a very nice idea
Khurana plays b3 and now although white
is okay with this setup here what will
always have to be careful about black
perhaps sacrificing this night on b3
because if Knight captures then you will
have to capture and black will have
created a very strong past a point but
okay Queen to a5 now a very strong move
as both the Queen and the rook are
attacking that night and c3 well the the
rock is x-raying yet after the knight
moves so a lot of interesting tactics
are possible here so first you want to
defend the night look the c1 and now
comes f6 and here is the first move in
the game where Corona should definitely
have gone for the head here karana
improved the position with King to g2
but he should have gone for H captures
on g6 and now after eight chapters on g6
ago immediately for this attack
threatened to capture and bring the
Queen over to h6 and now I flew up to f7
captures captures bring the Queen over
to h6 and now a lot of moves are
possible here for black but all of them
will be insufficient to defend if black
simply starts running away prepares to
bring the other look into the game then
this g5 move will be deadly but I want
to show this even though it's a blitz
game you know it's not very nice to over
analyze blitz but the g5 is a theme that
will be going throughout the entire game
for example now if Queen goes back to
help out now we get Knight to a5
threatening Queen captures here and now
everything wins for example if you
capture the night you get Bishop to h5
check that's why g5 is such a deadly
deadly move after the King moves
captures on f6 and now it's it's all
over here for black but first Corona
improved the position King to g2 and now
comes Knight the b4 and now the same
idea as you'll see does not work well
this night isn't before very
interestingly we have H captures H
captures Bishop h6 as in the variation
we've just seen look to f7 and now like
we said the same idea does not
if Bishop captures rook chapters and
Queen to h6 now we have Knight B to D
three attacking both the rock and c1 but
also threatening Knight to f4 check so
here if you try and create the same
setup Knight to a5 upon captors and g5
it will not work Knight to f4 check the
King now has to move and now F captures
and you haven't created anything here
with white you're just gonna lose but
after this rook to f7 karana played a
rope to h2 he's preparing to play rook
to h1 double up on the H file and then
create some threats against the black
king but there is one move and a move
that is it's impossible to see as it as
it is a bliss game but you're at home so
perhaps you wanna you want to pause the
position and of course the video and
find this very nice idea it's quite a
deadly move so you know if you would
like to do it I will give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent
you know supporter of the Knights the
Knights that go back as the move is nice
to d1 and here the idea is now nice to
e3 the c-4 to sorry 33 to c2 and attack
the the night here because the the idea
is that the queen is undefended on a5 so
you just want to attack the pin piece
with nice to e3 and c2 and now whatever
black plays let's say B 593 now black
will either defend this night by playing
nice to a6 or let's say you do this 936
rope captures Bishop captures and now
Bishop captures rook captures and now
you get a knight e to f5 again the the
idea is the same pawn captures and now
Queen to h6 will be winning whatever
black plays let's say King to f7 is
played again g5 this g5 move is so
strong always opening up this diagonal
for the attack and now after whatever we
better to h5 King gay fate G captures on
f6 again we have this exact same attack
happening and it's interesting after
this Knight to b3 if you don't do that
if you go something like a bush of to h8
which is stronger then white continues
with the plan you attack the pin piece
the knight on d4 black has to defend it
and now you simply start
an attack on the Kings side and the
black can't move anything here the
Knights can't move the Queen can't move
so just a you know an impossible
position to play but okay it's it's a
blitz game of course you're not supposed
to find 91 in a blitz game but I just
thought it'd be fun to mention roof to
h2 was played by Caruana
Bishop captures on h6 Queen captures on
h6 and now comes a rook to g7 rook see
to h1 now with this double rope Queen
battery and the h-file and here it's
it's a lost position for Hikaru but only
if not only if a Khurana plays it the
way it should be played
rook to f8 now Nakamura is ready to
execute his escape plan with the king
and here very interestingly is another
position where karana should have gone
for the head and played a very nice move
but here he retreated with Queen to c1
but again he misses the the the
strengths of the movie g5 and g5 is such
a strong move in every line because it
opens up this bishop and here whatever
you play let's say you try to escape
King to f7 you get Queen captures and g7
this is the beauty our King captures
rook checks King moves and now pawn
captures here and the threat is the rook
to g7 checkmate there's not much you can
do here you can only stall if you
capture then you fall to fall victim to
a different checkmate it's really just a
beautiful beautiful idea and again after
g5 if you don't try to escape
immediately if you try something
differently although there's really not
all that much you can do you can try
grabbing the pawn but then again Knight
to f5 the same idea applies better
captures pawn captures and after rope
captures you will get Queen h8 check
King moves and now rook to h7 and there
is no defense against Queen captures you
could capture back but then again you're
getting rope to captures on h7 checkmate
so really a wild wild position where if
you if you see g5 then you know
everything is winning but if you don't
consider g5 then you will not be fine
any of these moves so Queen to see one
Khurana retreated with Knight B to D
three now attacking the Queen Queen to
d2 and now comes Knight to f4 check
so already you can feel that Coronas
position was much better a few moves ago
as now the knight on f4 is such a
beautiful piece you're preventing the
Queen from joining the attack it's very
unlikely that White will get a second
chance King to g1 getting out of check
King to f7 creating oil making an escape
with the King and now with rook to h8
you could still continue playing this
game but Caruana here plays rook to h7
he wants to exchange rooks here but this
is a a deadly mistake as now Carwin
nakamura takes the initiative
he plays rook the c8 now you can really
see that this Knight is troublesome on
c3 so what do you do here if you just
move the Queen then you get Knight
captures nb3h craft a cappers and the
rook will capture on b3 the the past a
pawn will be just winning so here a
corona tried Bishop to c4 you can't
really move the knight and here we have
b5 attacking the bishop we have nice to
e2 and now comes g5 nakamura doesn't
allow her hornet to push g5 but it's
interesting if you play something like
rook captures on h7 black is still
winning
but Nakamura was so confident in his
position that he didn't go for this
forcing line nor did he look for it
because now after King g8 you attack the
rook rook moves and now comes Bea
captures in c4 but this is probably why
Nakamura didn't go for it because after
Knight captures pawn captures and Queen
captures you could see this position
from that position and say okay Queen
captures rook h8 I don't wanna allow the
checkmate and my position is very nice
but Queen captures on c3 grabs the
knight and defensive six black is
completely winning here but like we said
it's a blitz game
so g5 by Nakamura we have Knight
captures on f/4g chapters on f4 and now
comes
g5 here again with rook captures on g7 a
white could still play this game
King captures f3 is such a beautiful
move consolidating here and threatening
Queen to h2 and now it doesn't matter if
B captures on c4 you're just gonna go
Queen to h2 and now you can always
achieve a perpetual by by continuously
checking the black King but here I wanna
finally played g5 except the problem is
in this position it doesn't work here
Nakamura
moves the drug back from the active C
file to the G file there's no point in
capturing here that Bishop is just you
know stranded there
Bushra back to e2 karana brings the
bishop back and now comes King to f8 I'm
pinning but now came to f1 also on
pinning F capture son g5 and now comes
f3 we have before attacking the knight
Knight has to move and now comes the
idea that well it's most likely the the
theme of of playing the Kings engine
like this when you bring this pawn all
over to a 3/9 captures on b3 and now if
play captures then a2 of course is
winning there's no way to prevent this
point from queening so quran fright
Queen to c2 now we have night study for
attacking the Queen Queen has to move we
have Queen to c1 and now comes a b3 a
capture son b3 and here a nakamora
simply played a 2 and it was in this
possession a position that Fabiano
Caruana
resigned the game there is there are no
tricks here there are no ways for whites
to look for anything a 1 is coming and
it's it's just over so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and I also
prepared this for you
an excellent subscriber sent me this so
I really do hope you enjoy it I I was
staring at it and I really think it's
just just awesome you know really
captures the entire theme of my channel
so I don't know I might use he said it's
ok to use it for the merchandise so I
might find ways to use it but we'll see
how it goes and also as nakamora won his
match against Khurana
Nakamura 118 out of 28 also Maxine for
sherrilyn Grove won his match against
Lebanon into London chess classic with
18 out of 28 so also wanted to mention
that in the live blitz ratings Maxine
vasila grab
has overtaken Magnus Carlsen as the
world number one highest-rated blitz
player but I've seen an interview with
maxime beaugeois lagravis ed that he
wasn't all that impressed with this you
know it's obliterating it comes and goes
that Maxime still considers Magnus
Carlsen to be the strongest blitz player
in the world so very humble from the
Frenchman you know good things come come
from that definitely but yeah that's
what I wanted to share with you I'm
gonna check out some of the other games
I haven't really been following all that
diligently the into London chess classic
so I'm gonna definitely check up on some
of the games between Lebanon and Maxime
bar Sheila graph if you have a
suggestion of any of the games do
suggest I would like to thank Anderson
Diego Rivera all of us Abraham Abraham
Mel vain
Kevin oh Christmas Chris mcgahren and
the Gregory pay cert for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and thank you once again for for
you know getting me to to this number
one spot thank you all and I will see
you soon